Hey Dee, are you okay?
Oh, I'm sorry. Hi Chris!
Do you feel okay, Dee?
Yeah, I feel fine.
I'm just tired.
Didn't you get enough sleep last night?
Yes, I even went to bed early.
And you don't feel sick?
No, just really run down, like I'm a toy and my batteries are almost gone.
What did you have for breakfast?
Oh, I didn't have breakfast.
You didn't?
No, I woke up late today and was in such a hurry that I totally forgot to eat.
It was either find my matching headband or eat breakfast.
I'm really looking forward to lunch today.
Dee, that's it!
I know what's wrong with you.
You do?
Yes, you didn't have a balanced breakfast and your body is tired.
It is?
Every morning, I have a bowl of cereal, a piece of fruit, orange juice and water.
Yum! That sounds delicious!
It's more than delicious,...
...my body needs energy to get my brain going for a full day of learning.
I do sort of feel fuzzy.
It was really hard to pay attention in class today.
Remember how you said earlier you felt like your batteries were run down?
Well, let's pretend you're a toy car.
I'm a cute car.
Now pretend that your tummy is like the batteries for that car.
When the batteries are empty, what happens?
It stops.
Exactly! Now when you have a full charge in your batteries, you can go for hours!
All the way to lunch!
When you wake up in the morning, your batteries are empty.
In order to start your day right, you need to recharge with yummy fuel!
Skipping breakfast left your batteries totally empty.
Which is why you feel so tired now.